du soleil des pilotes amateurs et
professionnels et des centaines de
spectateurs le premier rendez vous des
bmx pro series au stadium national de
saint quentin en yvelines a tenu toutes
ses promesses samedi 26 mars l'événement
regroupait plus de 300 pilotes tout au
long de la journée sur un format digne
des jeux olympiques c'est une
confrontation ils sont huit sur une
butte de départ et c'est le premier qui
arrive au bout des 4 100 m logiquement
avec la fédération il ya une
classification qui elle est qui et qui
en partie prises avec les quatre
premiers et ça découle sort des
seizièmes des huitièmes des cartes comme
dans n'importe quelle discipline parmi
les pilotes des étrangers venus
découvrir la piste et s'imprégner de
l'ambiance en vue des jeux olympiques de
2024 à paris ils sont venus des quatre
coins du monde c'est vraiment cool d'été
ici la paix c'est franchement vraiment
rapide c'est un belle piste je pense que
c était vraiment cool de rouler avec
tous les pans son essai avec les publics
et tout ça ça a été franchement vraiment
cool sur ce stadium de bmx de 50 ans ni
ville on retrouvait également des
membres de l'équipe de france présent
sur les grands rendez vous mondiaux on
connaît bien la piste ici vix et le
centre d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france de bmx donc on connaît bien la
piste c'est toujours agréable de venir
ici ils ont bien préparé la piste ils
ont bien nettoyer tout ça donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment super elle est
particulièrement
particulièrement propre pour la
compétition et franchement ça roulait ça
roule super bien au delà des bonnes
conditions
nouveau rendez-vous bmx pro series est
déjà programmé en octobre prochain sur
le même format jusqu'en 2025 le stadium
de st quentin en yvelines devrait
accueillir au minimum deux compétitions
chaque année